all right let's get the flow going let's
feel the music and for nothing else
we're going to talk about uncle jesse's
favorite artist of all time but the fact
is i can't think about elvis without
thinking about stamos and that's on full
house before we get started i do want to
thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by truebill
truebill is an all-in-one finance
platform that helps you save more and
spend less lower bills monitor your
credit score and build your savings all
in one place you can set up budgets that
automatically monitor your spending
category visualize your spend earn ratio
and get notifications when you've
exceeded that budget cancel unwanted
subscriptions because we've all been
there sign up for a trial period then
you just kind of forget about it or you
sign up for a streaming service because
the show is going to air on that
streaming service again you forget about
it now you don't have to be a deer in
headlights when you get a notification
10 months from now that you signed up
for another year true bill just sniff
that out and that
is awesome so click the link below go to
trubill.com john's try it out for free
and unlock more features with premium
because look when we think of fun we
don't think of adulting but it is a
responsible thing to do i'm glad true
bill's here to help and now we're not
just going to talk about a biopic this
isn't a common biopic it's
it's a cautionary tale
so let's talk about it
[Music]
so elvis is a new film it's a biopic
directed by baz lerman it's funny
because bazlerman films for me they can
be hit and miss you know sometimes i'm
like i really like the angle the energy
i like what he was going for it landed
with me other times it kind of falls
flat elvis is one of those films that it
just the style and what baz luhrmann was
going for in execution it really clicked
with me first of all the baslerman style
the flare you look at the title you're
like yeah bash lerman directed that all
right and if we take one scene in
particular you saw in the trailer when
elvis just belts it out you know and
he's moving we've seen elvis footage and
you know it's easy to see elvis footage
like all right that was a big deal back
in the day i guess but we're coming from
our eyes now you know you know that it's
a big deal but there's a difference
between knowing and understanding the
energy that baz lerman brings to this
movie and the scenes where elvis is just
moving and all the women are just going
crazy in the audience it's like baz
lerman takes you to school in that way
you know you can have two different
teachers for the same subject and one
teacher can tell you everything
and it just doesn't land and the other
teacher just illustrates it to the class
in a way where it just clicks that's
what vaslerman does with elvis with the
energy he brings to the elvis story i
think i thought it really worked
surprisingly now austin butler plays
elvis presley i was kind of concerned
not because austin butler i thought he
looked great when i saw the trailer
elvis usually sounds like an elvis
impersonation in the way impersonations
sound it's kind of like my arnold
schwarzenegger impersonation it's not
that honor doesn't sound like this he
kind of sounds like this but this is
more exaggerated in that animaniacs kind
of way you get it right like so i was
afraid i was going to hear an
impersonation austin butler
sounds like elvis presley he sells you
on the fact you're like
it's just his voice words out scientific
advancements austin butler is an elvis
presley clone it's one of those roles
where by the end you see real footage of
elvis in the credits you're like
oh he looks different you kind of forget
what elvis presley really looks like
because you have accepted his elvis as
elvis very rarely does an actor actually
hit that point with me i thought he was
really impressive if his career doesn't
explode after this movie i've officially
lost
a lot more faith in humanity and i
already have a couple things the movie
does remarkably well is show you the
human being behind the legend you know
like the legend's still there i mean
granted it's a biopic they're gonna
dramatize something he's gonna make [ __ ]
up gonna bypass some of the other things
that maybe they don't want to talk about
but i appreciated the fact that we were
hanging out with this person elvis
presley who didn't ever seem to feel as
famous as his legend was to other people
out there he was just a guy who wanted
to sing sometimes it does play against
the film because you're like how much
time has gone by years will go by and it
doesn't seem like years have gone by
there's a part of me that doesn't even
want to touch on that in this video
because that's that's biopic 101 a
constant gripe i have not even gripe
just something i address is that it
seems like
it goes by the ears too fast you know
like the passage of time isn't properly
illustrated it feels like maybe it's
been a month maybe it's been years but
you don't really know all you know is
elvis went from hey i want to sing too
that's a big house and that's just the
way biopics generally are now the angle
that this movie came at i thought was
unique too you know because it's like oh
it's a biopic about a famous person that
can be kind of cut and paste but having
tom hanks narrate at the beginning kind
of sets the movie up to be seen through
his character colonel tom parker's
colonel tom parker's eyes but it
illustrates right up the gate that shady
is just a word and then there's this guy
playing this character who's a real
person who really saw himself as the
hero of elvis story he just
i don't know thought it was birthright
like they're [ __ ] in the world
they're just they're out there and
that's where this movie lands with me
this is actually the core of the elvis
movie for me it's a cautionary tale
because while there is one elvis presley
it is easier than ever to become famous
now in the information age that we live
in which means it's easier than ever for
these snakes these scumbags to find you
famous people out there on tick tock
youtube whatever taking advantage of
talented people on the rise
has happened since entertainment started
and it's not gonna stop anytime soon so
i love that this movie uses elvis story
to show that very relevant cautionary
tale for today and i felt this movie did
a good job at doing what i like biopics
to do
which is make a movie about a famous
person about a historical figure about
an artist but you don't necessarily make
it for people who are already fans elvis
fans will have a different relationship
with this movie than people who are not
elvis fans but you don't have to be an
elvis fan to take away something from
this movie i mean shoot i went into this
movie thinking okay it's gonna be elvis
the king of rock and roll vegas what can
i say i guess i only knew about the
legend of elvis didn't know too much
about the darker business side of his
life and how it's ever more apparent
that among famous people you show me a
rich and famous person i'll probably
show you someone who's drowning in their
sea of
sorrow and loneliness anyhow i really
dug this movie i was like dude this is a
two hour 40 minute movie oh god it's a
biopic let's well yours open and what i
ended up watching was a story that was
remarkably engaging remarkably human and
used baz luhrmann's energy to push the
film forward at a pace i enjoyed hell
yeah it's worth watching and i'll even
buy this one on blu-ray all right so
elvis
like those reviews a bit early and
that's that's a good sign too when this
screening happens over a week before the
movie comes out the embargo is already
lifted that's a good sign that the
studio has faith the movie's good but in
case you're watching this after you
already watched the movie have you seen
it what did you think about it what's a
biopic that you'd like to see maybe it's
one that's already been made maybe you'd
like it retold whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you